if i was to have a conversation with
vladimir putin
and or vladimir zelensky
is there something you would ask
about the time in the kgb
the time in his past
we are
all of us men and women are
creations of the experiences we have
throughout life early on in life and
through the formative experiences
successes and failures
so uh yeah you just said the key words
you know i would ask you know without
giving away anything
you know just being high level
your biggest success and your biggest
failure
as a politician or a kgb you'll be
talking in the realm of uh
uh kgb
when the wall came down and uh
he was in in
an office kgb office in the city of
dresden
and um
these germans were
uh
besieging uh stasi offices and they also
dropped by the kgb office and uh they
they were
that was pretty threatening it looked
like they won't actually storm the
office and get you know the
documents and stuff like that
and uh um
initially then the first demonstration
uh was uh
um
um was told that uh if if they come any
closer weapons would be used
so they disappeared and then they came
back and
i don't know some somebody in that
office called berlin and said what are
we going to do can are we allowed to use
force
and the answer came back that gorbachev
said absolutely not
and so this is where putin all of a
sudden you know he was at one point uh a
member of the greatest the most powerful
intelligence organization in the world
and all of a sudden he was powerless
and he had to
watch
how you know this this was a defeat big
one
and and it's a supposedly a powerful
intelligence agency cowering yeah sort
of
crawling back into a position of
weakness and he probably promised
himself never again russia needs to be
great again
the kgb fsb
russia the russian empire
needs to rise again and that there's a
feeling for him that that's as he talks
about the collapse of the soviet union
being a great tragedy
there's a feeling like
that was uh
um that was
like never again
yeah and and i i believe that uh
he has a he has a strong conviction
uh that
i don't know if he's religious he
carries across now but i don't know if
that what that means but
somehow but that uh
it's the destiny of the russian nation
to be great
and that that is sort of that that's
whether there's it's it's determined by
god or some some higher power that is
very important for him of course that
nationalist
idea is uh one that americans share as
well and
you know
it could uh help the nation flourish so
by itself is not necessarily a bad thing
oh it's how it manifests itself as a
great question
um well one other thing is
if i were to uh
get a chat with
the ukrainian uh
president i would ask him
how many lives
what what what
what is the equation between giving up
some land and how many lives
uh are worth this land
and that's a it's a good way to phrase
the question of course that question
gets you killed in ukraine
but uh because there's another part of
that equation
which is it's not just land versus lives
it's
the sovereignty
the knowledge that you're free
and you're self-determined
and like it's not about like fighting
for the particular land it's saying
we
are messed up
corrupt
um
we have problems it's a messy world
but
it's our world
uh i think stephen crane has a poem
about like
a man eating his own heart
and he was asked
uh how does it taste and he said it's
bitter but i like it because it is
bitter and because it is my heart
and that there's a sense of like i want
this is
not just about land this is our nation
uh the same love of nation that uh putin
has for russia the greater russia this
vision of this great empire
uh i believe ukraine does as well
they're
not every nate you know there's levels
to this game and ukrainian people are
some of the proudest people
throughout the history of the 20th
century throughout the history of
earth the polish people are proud people
you can just see
in world war ii
the people who said [ __ ] you
you're not having this we will die to
the last man though there's different
cultures that kind of
really hold their ground and ukrainian
people are that you know i have to admit
in that respect i'm a
uh i'm a bit of a coward i i could not
do what zelinski has been doing
uh i
um
i would
sort of
try try to find a way to
carve out
something that
i i can live with
however if
if
that force that evil force ghost gets to
my family
right there's lying
yes that's right
you're
you become the world's bravest man as
somebody across that line oh yeah
you mentioned something about you've not
been to moscow back
uh and that you it might not be safe for
you to travel there
yes
um can you speak to the nature of that
you know as somebody
somebody that successfully
got out of the kgb
how are you still alive
a number of reasons um first of all um
when
my story became public that was six
years ago
i was pretty old right and so
uh the folks that
may
have a personal interest or may have had
a personal interest in doing me harm
most of them don't live anymore all
right that's number one number two i i
did not uh
i wasn't a hired hand a german i did not
betray the motherland
that's a crime that is
punished by death you betray the
motherland that's
uh and um
and
and the other thing is um
if there is a you know that these kinds
of operations to assassination on a
in another country are very difficult to
plan and implement and if there's a list
of people that
they don't like i
may not be at the very top having said
that you know
if i wind up saying moscow or even in
countries like turkey where there's a
lot of lawlessness you know accidents
can easily be uh arranged and that's
just sending another message you know
just like you know we
we
we can do a lot of things powerful yes
do you think it's safe for me to travel
in russia and ukraine uh
i think you uh you know
very well
how to communicate in both countries you
know you've shown this in this
interaction that uh
you have a lot of empathy for the people
you'll be talking with and empathy means
good understanding where they're coming
from
and then there are lines that you can't
cross yeah like the question that i was
going to ask zielinski who not going to
ask good for you
yeah isn't that the funny thing about
this world there's lines there's lines
everywhere even in love even in personal
relationships there's lines you should
not cross
you